today I want to begin by talking about
the crisis of masculinity in our culture
because that is what we're facing
there's an epidemic of confused
directionless depressed broken young men
and it's incredibly clear to me that
this is rooted largely though not solely
in a scarcity of male role models
specifically a catastrophic lack of
present devoted fathers in the home this
crisis is also driven by while at the
same time it's a culture that is deeply
hostile to young men a culture which
seems dedicated to demoralizing them and
preying on their weaknesses
and this problem is very personal to me
because I have two sons with two more to
be born sometime in the next couple of
weeks if not a couple of days which
means I will eventually be sending four
young men off into this cultural void
and so I spend much of my day every day
thinking about how to prepare them for
it
that is also the lens through which I
view the Andrew Tates of course is the
former kickboxer turned social media
personality Who Rose to prominence as a
voice of the so-called manosphere with a
message directed primarily at young men
and over time he amassed a large and
devoted following within that group but
not really becoming widely known outside
of that demo until big Tech decided all
at once several months ago to kick him
off of every platform and they did this
ostensibly on charges that Tate
expresses outrageous and objectionable
views allegedly which they decided no
one should be allowed to say and more
importantly no one should be allowed to
hear
but not for the first time however the
the effort to erase and unperson someone
only had the opposite effect of making
them more influential and more famous
and better known than they'd ever been
before I could say in my case
um I'm one of I think probably millions
of people who before they erased him
from everything I I I'm not sure I'd
ever even heard his name before
so I became acquainted with him because
they were trying to suppress it I know I
I you said that and I was wrong you said
that it's going to make him more famous
and I said I don't know but him getting
on like Fox news it got all the old
people watching them that's how all like
the the people your age
no I don't know that they were watching
him but they they became acquainted with
him and and yeah but now people your age
are familiar with Tate for the most part
oh my God look at all the ants and the
grandmas well yeah but they're like the
base grandmas like they all you know
they but they watch because I'm a
YouTuber but now because of them though
they're all their friends are are
watching our YouTube channel or at least
watching their shows and they're all
familiar with Andrew Tate and um yeah I
I think that because he's now also
really been all over the mainstream
media you know they're they're reporting
on this everybody knows who he is and I
think uh yeah I was proven right he's
just getting bigger and bigger no yeah
this Vice documentary that just came out
is so dooky I wonder what all the libs
and um
Hitler they didn't do this to Epstein
they didn't do the this to Balenciaga
they didn't do this to anyone that did
anything actually bad they're taking the
lover boy method and they're calling him
a sex trafficker and going after him
with all this nonsense complete nonsense
which was a positive result in my view
if for no other reason than the fact
that the sensors and D Platformers
deserve to have their efforts backfire
in such spectacular fashion so anytime
they try to cancel someone and that that
person becomes more famous I'm happy
because they deserve they the the
cancellers and uh and uh the Platformers
deserve to have that result now the most
recent update on Tate is that he was
arrested last week by Romanian
authorities on charges of sex
trafficking he says that this is simply
just another attempt by the powers that
be to punish and silence him meanwhile
the powers that be say that he raped and
sexually exploited multiple women that's
what he's accused of
now as for my opinion on the man I I can
say nothing about the criminal charges I
simply have no idea whether he's guilty
or not his accusers will have to prove
his guilts in a court of law when it
comes to the less serious matter of his
allegedly offensive opinions I would say
that
some of his opinions are indeed
objectionable in my view though
certainly not deserving of censorship
while some of his opinions are not only
correct but insightful and important
he's a human being in other words not
right all the time not wrong all the
time I tend to concur with Ben Shapiro's
take on Andrew tatus he expressed in his
podcast a few days ago Tate is very
often good
at identifying some of the problems
especially as they pertain to the
situation that men face in the culture
so for example here's a video you posted
on his Twitter page a few days ago cut
from an earlier interview with Tucker
Carlson and this is an example of the
good stuff uh let's listen to that
tell us what your message is to young
men yeah so I think that being a man is
very very difficult I think that men's
issues are largely overlooked a lot of
young men growing up today that feel
very disaffected they feel invisible the
agendas that are being forced down their
throats are not agendas they align with
or they feel Affinity to or agendas they
want and I basically just say to men
look it's a very hard life you're going
to need to get up work hard go to the
gym strong body is a strong mind you're
gonna have to reject listening blindly
to everything you're told reject the
slave mind think of yourself get a
strong network of Brothers work aside
them don't tolerate low quality people
in your life which means don't tolerate
men who just smoke drugs and play video
games and try and build and create a
reality full of high quality people in
which you can resist the programming
that the Matrix drives the influence you
with and grow up truly happy you know
and people so like they'll say like yeah
well that's good but the other stuff is
says is bad and it's like you know what
it really isn't that bad because like if
you listen to him talk with context a
lot of the time it makes sense like 99
of the things almost all of the things
that they try to say he's like actually
wrong about it's just taken out of
context I want to give this clip from
the PHD course for example this is
something that you know when they watch
every single minute of his thousand
hours of footage they didn't decide to
include ask someone which wants
oh my God I told what to do what to do
come with me if she says no that's
perfectly fine remember you're not
[__] psycho I don't know any of you
[__] getting rape charges and
the police finding this video and come
after me for it because I ain't done
nothing [__] wrong anybody just
saying you're clear I'm going we're all
going to mind or I'm going to mine to
come with me oh no I really want to go
home no problem you do not ask twice
even the woman's tough it's honestly
good advice a lot of the time that's
good advice like I this is the stuff I
listen to and then when I'm with girls
and they're like obsessed with how I'm a
gentleman and stuff it's like oh yeah I
got that from my mom and from listening
to some men on the internet and your dad
yeah my dad too you know what I mean
like my parents but like
it's just so funny how like the the PHD
course which they're acting like it was
like a course on how to rape women
realistically that's not what it is at
all it was so that Vice that Vice
documentary was so slanted it was like
they wrote it before they met him and
they just then tried to try to edit it
in order to fit the hit piece that they
were trying to accomplish it is
now all that is true it's good that he's
saying it it's also enough on its own to
get you de-platformed you don't need to
say anything more offensive quote
unquote than what you just heard In that
clip to earn the ire of the left and of
our cultural Elites but where Tate goes
off the rails is in the remedy that He
suggests now some of his prescriptions
are reasonable and correct go to the gym
work hard uh build networks be around
high quality people I mean these are all
I don't disagree on on any of those
counts yet he also brags about sleeping
with many different women he promotes a
kind of ostentatious materialism saying
that the best way to be a manly man is
to make a lot of money and buy fancy
cars and show off your wealth he says
things like this tweet a couple of weeks
ago he tweeted this Genghis Khan had
endless women and 200 children as reward
for Conquest I am the most searched man
on the planet I have conquered Earth I
am the highest status male on the planet
females do not expect loyalty from me
they only expect that of lesser men
now this is not masculinity an
over-the-top blustering kind of ego
declaring yourself to be the highest
status man on the planet this is a sign
of insecurity not strength I mean any
time you feel the need to announce to
the public especially on social media
how great you are
um every single time you are doing that
because you are insecure no secure
person ever feels the need to do that no
man comfortable with his status feels
the need to brag about his stuff that's
right about that you think so like why
do they always go to like calling people
insecure like you're insecure if you're
confident or if you if you feel like you
need to say this like what's up it's not
no because he's not insecure like let's
just be realistic he's being really
cocky and obnoxious with that kind of
talk
no but but he does he does a lot of that
I'm the best man on the planet I'm the
baddest [__] on the planet and I
think that's what a lot of people like
this is what we bash him for but I think
that's what a lot of [__]
needed here is some confidence like that
and they need to look at themselves in
the mirror and think I'm the man you
know what I mean and that's what no
one's thinking that all we're told is
that men are [__] women are better you
know we need to just like you know put
our dick between our legs and you know
run off and cry and do all this nonsense
you were never told that that's what all
of them are telling us
oh my God a guy once in a while not at
home so that's where we just get a big
bigger Point keep your kids out of
schools that teach that stuff and
because they'll stick in the end with
what they learn yeah but I'm just saying
like I just don't think it's as bad as
they all make it sound because like I
think men need someone like that with
confidence and to tell them to be
confident in yourself and if you want to
get to this level that I'm at where I am
the [__] man and I can justifiably
say I'm the man then you need to work
and get here no I get it what he does is
sometimes he'll he'll put himself on a
pedestal and he will insult other people
and I don't think it's ever okay to step
on someone else's neck or have to insult
people to prove your own worth if you're
that great it should be self-evident and
you shouldn't have to be walking on all
this and I'm all that I don't like that
as a personality Detroit and I think it
it is a way of putting other people down
if you're that great it just shines and
it shows I think a lot of what he does
you know I like Andrew Tate but when he
talks like that I just kind of roll my
eyes and look the other way and I just
think it's Hyperbole and it's part of
his a brand 100 to get attention I think
he's actually more uh humble and calm
than that in other interviews where I've
seen him being more relaxed yeah this is
this is his marketing and so you know
Matt I I don't know if Matt's going a
little too deep on it about him being
insecure because I think it's just his
brand worst of all Tate suggests that
loyalty is a virtue of lesser men which
could not possibly be more wrong yes
that is true that can be disloyal okay
anyone can be disorder any man
especially if he has a lot of money can
sleep with a bunch of different women
and discard them in fact any man with
not a lot of money can still do the same
if he's willing to you know go out and
buy the affections of a two dollar
hooker for a few minutes yeah but I
think that's different anyways like I
think you know obviously anyone can go
and buy a hooker but that's that's kind
of like an outlier of the point like if
you're going out and buying hookers
that's a different problem he was again
speaking and Hyperbole and and a lesser
a man with no money can go out and and
talk women and be a cheater and have
girls fist fighting in the gutter over
him it's unbelievable what goes on so I
you know I I think I think that loyalty
and keeping your word and honor are not
easy things and that's what uh is the
measure of a real man who was able to do
that and who has that that kind of
character so for I I completely disagree
with him and Genghis Khan was a royal
[__] so to make it seem like that's a
role model also not a good choice that's
not impressive much less a sign of
masculine strength
real masculinity I'm going to say like I
agree with you there like it's not like
it's not the most impressive thing that
you can go out and sleep with multiple
girls but I'm not gonna lie it is pretty
impressive that he can retain multiple
girlfriends at once like that is crazy I
that is nuts to think about like
thinking of the process of actually
doing that what is what is the the
mental state of these women that that
are okay with that I'm not even saying
that like I'm not preaching to go and do
that I'm not saying I'm gonna do it who
knows like that might be too much like
where I'm just like it's not worth the
mental space to have different girls I
don't care that much but you would lose
your [__] mind if I ask you to do as
your mother ask you to to do the same
thing twice you're like God damn it let
me know
okay now you're 19 you're gonna outgrow
some of that but the thought of you
having like three or four broads texting
you all day asking you what the plan is
well I'm saying that's my point like
it's crazy to manage all that like
that's impressive like that is
impressive because they have to they
have to swallow that importance of
monogamy inside of them and their
partner to be with him like you gotta
you gotta build yourself that much up as
a man or like the girls like they don't
care about it as much like that's a wild
thought I can't even imagine there is
not a man on earth that is worth that to
me but yeah but like this is your
billion dollars in top of it I don't
care real masculinity and also real joy
and contentment in life is found in the
man who remains loyal and devoted to his
family
this is not only the more difficult path
but it's the more rewarding path
by far yeah and it's also like agreed
like going and sleeping with a bunch of
random people isn't fulfilling like
having you know one woman that's like
not yours but like your girlfriend
that's like you're loyal too like yeah
it's it's not a bad thing like no no I'm
saying like sleeping around and like
doing all that [__] that's just like
Haram so he's right there loyalty and
humility
are both Virtues Of The truly masculine
men and yet they are virtues that Andrew
Tate explicitly militates against like
he's against those things and we'll say
so
so while he gives young men some good
and important advice he still winds up
leaving them ultimately
where they began which is stranded alone
confused
but the real question that we should be
asking in regards to Andrew Tate isn't
whether he's right or wrong about
everything he says
I would love to watch a conversation
between Tate and like Matt Walsh and Ben
Shapiro that'd be awesome I had a genie
would have wished that would be a good
one you know that's what you wish for
with the genie well if I had like a lot
of wishes and I kind of got run out of
things to wish for yeah
every time a new figure comes along
with a message directed at men
okay our cultural overlords will swoop
in immediately to discredit destroy and
silence that person every single time
these self-appointed Gatekeepers have
never met a man with a message for men
who they didn't find problematic and
misogynistic
that's because while Tate May Veer off
in various wrong you know what I find so
interesting about the Matrix is that
they still need people on the right to
be like the spokesperson and faces of
the right so even like the Matrix Asians
they chose like Matt Walsh Ben Shapiro
they were like all right you guys are
allowed to have your platform you're not
getting too crazy we'll let you be like
the face of the right wing movement
because like who knows where my channel
is going to go no why isn't Greg Gutfeld
banned and Jesse Waters and Tucker
Carlson that's a little more down the
rabbit hole but like it's all it's all
the Matrix let's just be real it is and
like there's something about where even
on like taco Tucker Carlson where he's
like giving him Andrew the platform to
speak you know people would be like yeah
that's why like Fox News is like the
truth because like they're letting him
speak but then it's like if you let
people think that like if you if you
give people like a piece of it and let
them think think that you are the truth
then you can still kind of say I'm
butchering this big time do you see
where I'm trying to go with it that if
you give people some truth your that
that takes over your credibility exactly
and then they they you gain credibility
you see my point but you get like a
broken clock gets credibility for being
registered twice a day I noticed that
and like device documentary when the
vice guy mentioned the point of Tate
beating up that girl in the video but
then right after he talked about the
video where the girl came out and said
it was it was play so like I saw that
and I was like all right he's definitely
including that to get us to think that
he's like
do you see my point now create one
little piece of balance that's like deep
Matrix [__] like this it's it's all it's
all controlled but um pretty it's a
pretty crazy thought Critics on the left
are concerned there is no Direction he
could take the message that they
wouldn't consider dangerous and toxic
well there is one I mean if he was
preaching a gospel of self-loathing to
men if he was telling young men to hate
themselves and apologize for being who
they are
he was talking about toxic masculinity
then they would shower him with praise
they'd give him a doctorate you know and
uh he'd have a book deal he'd get
glowing interviews on Good Morning
America
that is the only thing anyone is allowed
to say to men if you're addressing men
specifically okay in the public sphere
if you're saying hey men and then you
continue to have a message for them
the only acceptable message as far as
our culture is concerned is shame on you
stop being that way be more like a woman
I love masculinity and that's precise I
absolutely love masculinity and I love
femininity and I love the opposite black
and white you know yin yang that they
play against each other and they're
trying to make women more masculine and
men more feminine so that we're just
this smushy homogeneous human race it
doesn't get get you get my mouth out of
your nose and they're just trying to
make us all the same and it's so [__]
boring it's so gross it's unnatural it
doesn't feel right stop trying to take
away my femininity and try to make me
turn into a dude even in that public
interview video I made when I asked um
October and she was like doesn't he have
like a club where it's like men are
better and I was like no but he like
teaches men to be in touch with their
masculinity she's like yeah like I don't
know like why is that bad for a guy to
be in touch with his masculinity but
like girls can do some do whatever they
want and girls can be in touch with
their femininity like once it's my turn
to be in touch with like they can't
really they say they're feminists but
they really don't want women to be in
touch with their feminine I know it is
honest to be in touch with those Natural
Instincts to nurture and care for our
families what do they want like what's
their goal what do they want I don't
really know like if they could like like
Snap their fingers like the gender pay
Gap that's a myth okay they want they
want at least 50 of all uh all CEOs to
be female sister uh that's one thing I
keep saying as if that freaking would
make anything better I'm not even gonna
go down there it's not working it's not
working
and that's precisely why Andrew Tate and
guys like him resonate and they find
such an enthusiastic and devoted
following they are speaking to men in a
way that isn't resentful isn't
accusatory isn't condescending
and they are among the only people on
the national stage doing that so the
audience naturally goes to them to the
guy who isn't spitting in their face it
kind of makes sense
and as I said at the beginning a huge
percentage of young men are raised in
homes where there is no fatherly role
model
often isn't a father present at all and
and in so many other cases there might
be a father physically present in the
home but he's not present emotionally
spiritually psychologically he's not
present any other way he's just there
he's a lump on a log
so they're not taught how to be men how
to harness their masculinity how to
constructively use all of the energy and
aggression that's brimming inside of
them all right [__] it I'm starting the
new Fight Club starting a fight club I'm
gonna make I'm gonna buy it I'm gonna
buy a beaten no you're not you're not
allowed I'm gonna buy a beating down bar
and we're gonna just go there and just
[__] kill each other be there but you
will yeah I will
out in society they're greeted with
accusations and Scorn and they're told
that they must suppress their
masculinity feminize themselves
then a guy like Andrew Tate comes along
and says no it's good to be a man it is
good to be tough and strong why does it
even need to be said what what how I I I
I okay this I get so frustrated and
upset when I think about how far we've
come that this is the conversation we're
having that we're having a conversation
about trying to defend men from just
being what they naturally are and why we
have to do this is just the stupidest
thing in the world let men be where they
are this is again just smoke screen they
have us arguing about complete nonsense
as a smoke screen so that the
politicians and the power powerful
business people that own them can just
go about their business making money
polluting the Earth poisoning us with
you know genetically modified foods
convincing us that we need to kill the
cows we're over here poisoning us with
genetically modified foods that we pay
for and then they're over here they
cause cancer and diabetes and obesity
and all heart disease and then they're
over here making money on the other end
on help on the cures or the treatments
and I know they pay to make us sick and
then they they get paid to make us sick
and then they get paid to not even
really make us well to curate us and so
that's that's really what it is all
about and so they have us over here
arguing about foolishness and you know I
get angry as you know but then I have to
I have to really say when I remember to
just take a breath and step back and and
I get more you know into all these
conversations around religion that we've
had about Christianity and Islam when I
get into thinking about you know God's
role in my life and I just refocus on
that all of a sudden it just sucks the
power out of all this nonsense you know
what's and it really helps me to calm
down and realize that like this is not
what matters it just doesn't they prefer
to listen to him and they are justified
in preferring him considering the
alternatives
the correct response to Andrew Tate then
isn't to silence him and condemn his
followers it is instead to say yes
he's right it is indeed good to be a man
and then to follow that
with a better and clearer vision of what
it means to be a man and how a man
should behave what his roles and Duties
are what direction he should go
because that's what these young men are
looking for they're looking for
direction and guidance
if you don't have that to offer
then just step to the side they're much
better off listening to Andrew Tate than
to someone who believes that the best
version of a man is a woman
what we should be telling young men
what I will and do teach my sons is that
a man
has a noble calling to protect and to
provide he is uniquely equipped to
fulfill this role and was made by God
for that purpose he is a protector he is
a provider that's what a man is supposed
to be
that is what every man is supposed to be
every single one
and any man who is not that who is not
doing that
will will will fall into despair here
about xqc because what about xqc nobody
you know xqc I never told him did I ever
show you the video of xqc reacting to
that to you roasting him
the results of feminism gone wild
turning men into women that's what they
want to do and look they've done it
[Music]
look at his face I want to know what he
says
that is just
what the [__] is
I'm gonna be honest that woman received
so much backlash from xqc's at Cube
community that she even apologized no I
didn't yeah when did that happen I
apologize just a common YouTube I would
repeat that right now use the results of
feminism Gone Wild
she's useless
and the worst thing that a man can be or
feel is useless
nearly every man who has committed
suicide and the suicide rate among young
men is increasing
and nearly all of them it's it's in part
because that's how they felt about
themselves useless there's no point to
their life nothing for them to do
so this is what a man is made to be
and most men are meant to find the
ultimate fulfillment and expression of
that role a protector and provider in
the family as father and husband not all
men though some men are called to serve
in another way
but all are called to serve all are
meant to live their lives in service to
something greater than themselves no man
is meant to live aimlessly wandering
from place to place motivated merely by
the drive to satisfy his desires from
one moment to the next well I I I've
talked to you about this that you know
everybody needs a purpose yeah and this
is why they create these fake problems
and latch onto them so that they feel
that they have a purpose because they
don't ever really take the time to align
with what their true purpose might be
because they think they need it it needs
to be a big bold purpose and when it may
be just as simple as providing for your
family and protecting your family as
he's talking about that's what a guy
wants to do is just provide and protect
it's like that's like intrinsically
that's just what the guys want to do and
if you can't you feel like you feel like
a [__] I think though that a lot of
that uh Natural Instinct that's why
you're born with is really Jarred and
interrupted by trying no yes okay like
imagine that there's you know arrows of
[__] ruining somebody you know from the
second they're born hitting them and
wounding them and the Matrix you know uh
an abusive or absentee father or an
alcoholic mother sexual abuse from a
priest or teacher or somebody you know
outside the family unit they don't know
me son you know like all those things
really start to interrupt you know that
natural Rhythm and it's hard to get it's
hard to get back to and I think that's
what Tate is trying to do he's trying to
say forget all the noise forget all the
[__] that happened in your life you
can sit and whine and cry about it or
you can just man up and build yourself
build yourself into something and that's
and that's a message that why is that
dangerous because it's dangerous to the
powers that be imagine if everyone in
America had that mentality and we were
like truly strong individuals with a
common mindset how different would this
country look well the people in charge
would have to answer to us that's for
sure it's a crazy thought like I think
about that even with like them arresting
Tate it's like dude the the people who
are are in control if he can leave or
not are probably Tate fans like if all
of us were just like [__] this we're not
listening to you like what would they do
about it what would they do if we were
all just like nah yeah no I'm done yeah
all the all the people in the military
nah I don't feel like I don't feel like
doing that no I don't believe that like
no like what would they do would this
one Sergeant would he go and just start
whooping everyone no if everyone was
like [__] that that's not how it would
go it's crazy it's crazy thought no man
can find fulfillment in that life but
that is the life many are condemned to
because they've never been shown another
way
because because the the cultural powers
that be have decided that we're not
allowed to show them another way our
culture tells men that they're not
called to do anything in particular that
their sex should have no bearing on what
they do or how they interact with the
world
and we call this freedom
but it's the sort of Freedom you give to
a man in the desert by taking away his
compass and his map
you take that all away you say yeah I
see you're free now to wander and go
nowhere
and die and die that's not Freedom
that's despair
which are two things that are very often
conflated these days
is it any mystery that these wandering
men would so eagerly follow the first
guy who comes along and seems to know
where he's going
if his map isn't as reliable as he
thinks or claims
well it's better than no map at all
because if you're completely lost
you might as well follow whoever claims
to know the way even if he takes you
inside okay so that's exactly that's
exactly what's happening is with with
all this left ideal this woke ideology
is that they they are coming along
saying I have a map follow me I'm going
to show you the way to be the most
awesome person and be righteous and be
wonderful and they're and they're
winning a lot of people and now they're
seeing him come along and people who are
looking over their shoulder going but
wait I could how about that and it's and
it's they're pissed yeah because it's
they lose money they lose power every
time somebody defects to another way I
like the analogy we cannot push away all
of the people who are trying to guide
these young men only to replace their
voices with silence
not only silence just garbage I mean
it's so obvious that like the people
that like when there's that interview of
the the lawyer interviewing the guy
Tate's lawyer was getting interviewed
and he was like you know Tate thinks
that it's like Global Elites that don't
like that he's speaking too much and
that they're trying to cancel him he was
like hahaha like it's a big conspiracy
and I'm like bro are you kidding me
that's what you're going after him for
like get out of here everybody could go
they could find something on everybody
to go to jail on everybody if you ever
slept with a girl looks like you raped
her I smuggled a dog in you smuggled the
dog in from Mexico when you were 20. you
can go to jail I had a wife
arrest in Texas once why because there
was a speeding ticket and I didn't pay
it I forgot about it and they had a
warrant for your arrest yeah and so we I
so I was driving from the east coast to
the West Coast got a speeding ticket on
the way totally forgot about it and uh
then a few months later I was back home
at Grandma's house and my driver's
license was still at her house and uh
she she came in the kitchen and she she
was like what is this what is this and
it was a it was a thing that said there
was a warrant out for my arrest because
I didn't pay the speeding ticket and I
never showed up oh and she was probably
freaking out I thought it was fantastic
did you ever end up paying it or
anything I don't remember I must have I
what I the thing that really stands out
you would be amazed how much you can get
away with if you refuse to comply I I
was just ignore ignore ignore myself
that I was wanted in Texas you know
there was one time I I like I I
understand that [__] that he says where
it's like you could get away with so
much if you just refuse to comply so
much stuff is just Scare Tactics to get
you to do it and if you just didn't do
it nothing would happen yes yes but
don't take that to mean don't pay your
taxes no no but you know because because
you know I you're 19 and your brain
isn't fully formed and you can take that
into extreme I was gonna tell you a
story in 10th Grade I got caught
cheating in chemistry and when you get
caught cheating you're supposed to go to
the principal and you're supposed to
write a letter or like go tell him that
you got caught and give him this form
and write this email and all this but
and tell your parents you never found
out till now and I never did it I didn't
do it I was the one kid that just was
like nah
I'm not doing it like if I if I don't do
it you come tell me and like remind me
in like emails to do it I'm not doing it
and I know he just didn't remind me and
I didn't get in trouble but guess what I
could have just gone and done it and for
what and I wouldn't have even gotten I
didn't even get in trouble and had a
whole song and dance from the principal
your teachers detentions you were in
detention all the time anyway oh I would
have had done would you I would do with
you guys I would have wanted to shoot
myself Sonny you've been late 27 times
this year I have a video where I was get
I'm getting yelled at in the principal's
office yeah we have to find that oh my
God I'll find it I have it you want to
see it real quick on the third you came
to school at 9 15. no parent no no no
call no no and that was on the third
October 3rd so I'm just sitting there
laughing that was that BC high yeah and
I I mean I like that guy he's I'm so
cool with him said he was always in
detention there was there was this
system that I could log into and I I I
I'm kind of like you and I logged in
like sometimes and you are always you
always had a reason why you were like
home late or getting you know leaving
late for school or whatever you know I
was just like whatever and then one day
I logged in and it showed like
whatever it was like dozens of jugs and
I was like you you go to detention every
day and he's like yeah pretty much
hahaha
I couldn't even get mad because I was a
detention kid too thank you guys so much
for watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfast
follow me on Sonny's mother and we'll
see you later
[Music]